as energy and optimism is fading barack
obama arrived in glasgow with a
half-time call to ask obama
collectively and individually
we are still falling short
we have not done nearly enough to
address this crisis
i have to confess it was particularly
discouraging to see the leaders of two
of the world's largest emitters
china and russia declined to even attend
the proceedings
and their national plans so far reflect
what appears to be
a dangerous lack of urgency a
willingness to maintain the status quo
on the part of those governments
you can see all the excitement around
president obama he's bringing a
much-needed injection of enthusiasm into
this flagging summit but what it really
needs is an injection of cash
his speech got a standing ovation at 12
years on from the copenhagen climate
talks a 100 billion dollar pledge for
poor countries the u.s unveiled still
hasn't materialized it's damaged trust
in the rich nation's commitment to
helping poor countries adapt to a world
they didn't make warmer
i want leaders to acknowledge that loss
and damage is here with us now
communities from countries like mine in
the global south they're already on the
front lines of the climate crisis
they're things that we can no longer
adapt to we cannot adapt to extinction
we cannot adapt to starvation we cannot
adapt to our lost cultures or our lost
traditions or our lost identities there
has been new money pledged for
adaptation at these talks 3 billion from
the u.s last week and nearly 275 million
from our government today but will it
materialize he can pull a crowd but mr
obama only secured a third of the green
finance money his administration
promised in paris
we're not losing hope in not losing
faith we're continuing to believe that
it can become a reality because without
that becoming a reality what do we have
where do we go
so we don't want to lose that faith and
we don't want to lose that hope but it
is being stretched towards it it is it
is
but as i said we're not losing faith and
we're not losing hope
faith and hope are what these talks need
right now that and a lot more ambition
otherwise an even more difficult task
gets passed on to the next cop a year
from now and a year closer to the worst
of climate change tom clark sky news
glasgow